la crise diplomatique entre la russie et
la république tchèque touche les
échanges entre les deux pays de
gouvernement tchèque exclu de l'appel
d'offres pour la centrale nucléaire de
du covan y ait une société russe frag
qui a aussi annoncé l'expulsion de 18
diplomate en réponse un sabotage imputés
à des agents russes
elle a demandé cet après midi à ses
alliés de l'ue et de l'otan de faire de
même en retour moscou expulsé 20
diplomate tchèque moscou où l'on
retrouve notre correspondant antoine
clairon
la russie a pris acte des décisions de
la république tchèque des décisions
lourdes en conséquence diplomatique
politique est également économique en
effet l'entreprise russe rosatom a été
exclu d'un appel d'offres dans le
secteur du nucléaire à porte parole de
la diplomatie russe de son côté trouve
bizarre quand cette année denquête rien
n'était et trouvé et que tout d'un coup
de nos russes apparaissent soudainement
il y a eu enquête il mener une
investigation
cela a duré sept ans et cela n'aboutit à
rien il avait besoin de présenter
quelque chose au public
et alors ils ont trouvé petrov et punchy
roms est une honte
oui c'est une honte est ce une insulte
aux citoyens tchèques sans aucun doute
mais apparemment il n'avait pas d'autre
option
derrière eux se trouvent les états unis
qui doivent poursuivre leurs propres
projets programmes et objectifs
géopolitiques
tous convergent en un point on l'a
entendu la russie estime que washington
se trouve derrière cette affaire le
porte-parole du kremlin ne dit pas autre
chose et regrette que les relations
bilatérales entre la russie et la
république tchèque souffre ainsi de ces
nouvelles accusations sans fondement
première chose
certes nous estimons que ce comportement
de la république tchèque est tout à fait
dénué de fondement deuxième chose nous
estimons qu'il est destructeur pour les
relations bilatérales
bien évidemment nous sommes d'avis que
cette politique de prague est dépourvu
de bon sens
tout cela a l'air de tentatives de
ressembler en prenant des mesures
imprévisible et agressive à leurs aînés
de l'autre côté de l'océan
on a cette impression et le langage du
ministère des affaires étrangères est
tout à fait approprié parce que cette
décision ces accusations non étayées et
dépourvue de fondement formulées par nos
adversaire tchèque sont de toute
évidence scandaleuse et ne peuvent être
ni comprise ni analysé outre le renvoi
de diplomate et l'exclusion de rosatom
prague a fait savoir qu'elle ne ferait
pas appel aux vaccins russe spoutnik v
et ce même si ce vaccin venait à être
acceptée venait à être autorisé par les
autorités sanitaires européennes